one of the cool parts about doing the
Cantor Brown ride is that you're out so
that allowed to lay out here look at
this a couple to the left of us getting
all comfy and [ __ ]
I like that I didn't nobody gonna do
with me but y'all get your ass over here
be a couple of me
[Music]
so the sea captain allowing us to come
out here in front of the catamaran and
lay out on the net and it's actually a
pretty cool experience because it feels
like you're actually sailing across the
water I'm a little bit apprehensive
about this specifically because I'm like
250 pounds and Mission my step with a
pipe I have when I'm out here with my
boyfriend Joe and look at him enjoying
himself
[Music]
it is the second day and today is going
to be a very fun day because I'm at my
favorite part of the island which is the
North Shore I'm not too keen on Waikiki
when you see a whole bunch of tourists
with their push in there shoving it kind
of reminds me of like a Highland Las
Vegas I actually love the North Shore
usually when I come to Oahu I stay out
here but today were to be doing
something special we're gonna be
snorkeling on this catamaran and we're
also going to be looking at the island
in the ocean I'm out here today with Joe
and Jess usually when we come to Hawaii
we're super relaxed we're not doing a
lot of things because honestly most of
the times when we're out here is simply
just asleep just because our regular day
schedules are so hectic but I made a
commitment to myself the next time I
come back to Hawaii we were going to
have fun
we're gonna do like adventurous [ __ ] I
haven't actually been into the ocean
directly off of the boat so this is
actually something very new for me
usually I go to Hanauma Bay where you
know the waters pretty shallow and if I
want I could just like paddle right back
to shore but this is gonna be directly
into the heart of the beast so get ready
to see me so we are about to stop off
and we're gonna get ready to put on our
fears to try them on but it's time to
make it happen it's time to see these
damn fishes I'm on the show these
[ __ ] what's up they may have
seen other circles but they using us not
gonna like me I like to go in things
overly confident because in reality I
suck we're about to go ahead on this
water I check out what's poppin him
there just gets a little seasick so she
had to look out into the ocean and
balance her body out like a little punk
as you can see today that of God the
great the difference in our color I'm
nice and golden she's the snow princess
and what happens with snow princess when
Sun hits them they turned into a
tortilla like joe says she needs to
protect that beautiful that's right in
20 years I don't want her to die of
cancer so I'm trying to keep her around
for a long time thank you
well some of you've been here before but
welcome to Waimea Bay what we're gonna
do is have Camille up so you can be your
tour guide slash lifeguard hope we can
find some pearls Dory Nemo all those fun
guys tell you one thing before we go
kepta marks at all it is like niemals
and things but I want to give you a
heads up that the disability is not good
because of the rain we have a lot of
Springs and more I saw all the fresh
water goes to the ocean making the
disability awesome good but we can have
fun by making Canada Bob contest or
and I'm really Oh wasn't quite ready so
if y'all have never been snorkeling
before simple stuff apparently if you
have a mustache or a lot of facial hair
and causes your mass do not seal very
well some water will get it popping that
put a little spray here a little defog
expressed it within a [ __ ] water blow
it out just be put into fine
I put it on cap ties in I feel like you
say agent mom washing their kid could be
an Amish [ __ ]
[Music]
we are at one of my favorite places out
in Oahu now I'm talking about plate
lunches now if you don't know what plate
lunches are clearly you're not Hawaii
now but Yama's fish market if you get
here early enough they get their fish
looking fresh in the morning ahead they
have some of the best poki I've had on
this island you guys might know of
another place that's different but this
is my personal favorite spot I'm about
to grub and get down we just got done a
sailing our asses off and clearly you
got to feed this beast because this
Olympian body doesn't happen without
having a nutritious meal to feel it we
just ordered our food got this the
delicious holy grail of Hawaiian food
I'm talking about kalua pork I'm talking
about Lao Lao I'm talking about lomi
lomi salmon and this beautiful mound of
delicious white rice I'm starving I'm
gonna get into this and take a little
bit of that smoky delicious kalua pork
I
we've got with them rice and of course a
little max salad on the side doesn't
hurt anybody
get that loud
[ __ ] delicious all you need this you
need the lomi lomi salmon to break up
all the fatty and saltiness and all the
other dishes and of course
nothing says Hawaii like fresh bouquet
now when I was in Japan I actually found
out there's a couple of places on earth
that gets first pick when it comes to
tuna or ahi it's gonna be Japan and then
Hawaii is next so basically what that
means is that they get the freshest
stuff and on top of that it also means
that it's going to be cheaper than
anywhere else that you're going to get
it so the three types that I got first
up is going to be the Hawaiian style
bouquet which is just like sea salt
green onions I think some sesame oil
some Kukui nut in there as well it's
very simple delicious fresh seafood EQ
so heavenly goodness next up we got Aki
again but we got it with the wasabi of
moussaka and I think they mix a little
bit of mayo in there as well with green
onions a food a [ __ ] a spicy delicious
this is my [ __ ] right here mother get it
with a bite of rice like this
can I just get a moment please douchebag
prayer and finally this is actually
Joe's favorite this is going to be the
show you pope gay this is his [ __ ] right
here it actually reminds me flavor-wise
of this thing called um hey job and head
Jang is rock green crab and they
marinated in soy sauce it has a very
similar profile talking about soy sauce
ginger salt green onions onions as well
and that's my ship now I'm pretty sure
you can get this food at a lot of other
places in Hawaii but this is my personal
favorite they have a little bit of
everything that I want and after this
we're gonna dig it to the desert but I'm
gonna shut the [ __ ] up and grub on this
so give me a second
[Music]
we gotta wake up David so we could go
eat
good morning David moving in my 15 we're
gonna eat dinner I almost have breakfast
I just woke up - good evening [ __ ]
welcome and where am I welcome you to my
friends I am welcoming you to after yo
now if you haven't been to your photo
format alley it's actually a spot out in
Waikiki that has a food court that
features a lot of different Japanese
cuisine now if you go around here and
you have your craving Japanese food this
is the spot to go to now a restaurant
that I actually really loved at this
place in this place called medium curry
house now I'm eating curry house
features Japanese curry outside of Japan
is actually really hard to find a place
that that's like authentic Japanese
party with Japanese chefs and this place
does it so whenever I'm in Hawaii this
is the spot that I go to the chef is
actually going to make us three dishes
it's going to be their steak curry their
katsu curry and they're gonna have a
special dish which is actually their
pink curry I've never heard of that
before but I'm excited to test it out
see what it's about
and if it's just as good of the stuff
that I've always been eating and you
already know there's gonna be bombs we
are here with the chef and general
manager Sean hey nice to meet you hi so
what makes this very so different from
other other
the condom
and a Famicom always have a Democrat
I actually have joka jest with me here
today and Joe and Jess because I've
already had the curry before I actually
brought them here because I wanted them
to try it out which one do you guys want
to try all of them let me get the middle
sorry you want it you want to eat it
okay here I go
I think you're gonna really like the
crazy sauce because it's it's actually
you know not too heavy so she loves
curry but she can't ever finish her
plate because the sauce is yeah but in
it really is really clear and she never
says that yeah it's not it's not overly
fatty what I noticed when the steak came
out is it and it came out like sashimi
it was like super rare you know that I
got it okay I'm gonna eat the whole
thing
mmm
oh my card saw I don't know which piece
I should get you like it yeah and it's
the same curry sauce right melts in your
mouth yeah no I'm gonna try this myself
I should never got to try the revive
before but we all know that ribeye is
one of everybody's favorite choice at
yeah super fatty I'm trying to get as
much curry on it as possible so good
that's true we have maybe three curry
chains like this Korea House and very
curry or something like that but it's
not good like this and I think it's
because they don't make it from scratch
and then they cheat by using cubes or
whatever I don't know so they actually
brought out a special tissue which I've
never seen before
yes it's a curry it looks like a dessert
like strawberry yeah how did you come up
with this idea
so this green is actually a - my
addition let me do this the sauce this
is really interesting to me Oh No okay
well that's interesting yeah we good no
it's good it's like trying to figure it
out in your mouth yeah it's it's almost
like a corn potato puree like look out
okay
yeah it's pretty good and then get all
of that yeah
the cool thing about this is you're like
I was saying before some of my favorite
restaurants like I don't even know I
didn't know prior talking to the chef
but because it's handcrafted he's made
it so much like it's kind of hard to me
to say on-the-spot vocals in the car
because there he makes it so often and
that's what I love about these type of
foods when somebody cares about their
food it tastes bad so if you guys are
ever out here and Waikiki and you guys
ever come out to the gourmet alley make
sure that you get meaning if you love
Japanese curry you will love this place
it's like one of my favorite spots to
pump to and I've only been here one time
before but every time I come back like
I'm gonna come here because it's so good
thank you so much thank you thank you
but he came with three ships right and
all of his men so they welcomed in
warmly and they feasted them in Dedham
and got him laid and all that so they
said oh and but his whole journey was to
find the northeastern Passage to India
to find spices so he took off any trim
pieces now we got a job to do British
right you go look at all these chicks we
got a job to do and all the sailors like
they went on their adventure and then
they broke their masts a month you know
in there boys
so you know where Hawaii is let's go get
some tree and cut it down make a new
mass so they came back but they miss
Hawaii they found a big Island this is
the time of Connie so they weren't too
friendly
hey Galen water they gave them bread
fruit then by this time his men were all
Randy because they had this land they
were warmly welcomed met girls were so
they thought they could do the same
thing at this time of year but the
people there when do to the wrong time
do so they killed